[Music]
there's so much going on and honestly a
lot of it's depressing it's pretty easy
to get dispirited and down
that happens to us one of the first
people we call is our friend
dana perrino because she's seen it and
she stayed cheerful throughout it
tomorrow she's got a new book related to
this the book is called everything will
be okay
life lessons for young women from a
former young woman
obviously dana is the co-anchor of
america's newsroom in the morning coast
to the five
and we're happy very happy to see her
tonight dana congrats on the book
thank you for having me the title um
everything will be okay will it how do
you know that
well it will um but it doesn't mean that
that's a passive thing right
the book is about action so i wrote the
book because i felt like
young women and you're you're a dad of
daughters right so
you know that they are talented they are
ambitious
um but they are racked with anxieties
and worries
and they put a lot of pressure on
themselves they have some insecurities
and i want to tell them like first of
all you won life's great lottery you
were born in america
secondly if you're an educated woman and
you are loved by your family
you're in the driver's seat and
everything will be okay but you have to
start making really good
decisions you have to be disciplined i'd
say that there's freedom and discipline
you have to make good you have to take
personal responsibility but also you
have to find a way
to transform that energy that you've
seen
which is the worry and the doubt and the
concern and
turn that into fuel so that they can
find some serenity and i include even in
there something i call a serenity
checklist
because i feel like a lot of them are
you know worrying their 20s away
and it's following them into their 30s
it's holding them back from
opportunities from jobs promotions
even personal relationships so i'm so
excited for people to finally get this
book in their hands
i want it to be their guide to just
making them feel a lot better
well it seems like one of the keys to
not worrying so much is just getting
older
i mean don't you think you reach an age
where you realize actually
a lot of this doesn't matter at all and
won't be remembered isn't of cosmic
significance
so who cares so and and that's another
reason that i say
everything will be okay life lessons for
young women
from a former young woman so it's in a
way you know take it from me i have a
chapter in there
so like who is dana perrino anyway i
also talk a lot about
integrity how that is your most valuable
asset
you have to protect it at all costs and
i talk about something called
kindness endorphins a lot of people love
to exercise because they get endorphins
but studies show tucker that the more
kind you are to others
the more it can reduce your anxiety and
i think that that then helps
unlock things plus this book is coming
out a year
anniversary to our two-week lockdown to
slow the spread
yeah for many people work has changed
quite dramatically we're not so much
just working from home
we are living at work so i have some
tips in there how to basically
network and stay relevant even though uh
you know a lot of people are still
working from home although it's getting
better
i love the kindness endorphins wow i'm
excited to read this book
thank you dana and you were a believable
person to write it that's for sure
thanks thanks so much